he said it's tasteless in Savannah and
today we're going to be trying meals
from single guys I'm cute I'm iffy like
we're single guys yep we made some food
for some single ladies
yep they're gonna pick which meal they
like best and they're gonna too so they
want to go on a date on afterwards I
think I'm gonna win yeah I'm pretty
confident I cook a lot cook all the time
when I chef I chef you know it's not
just like no play play I'm gonna do my
thing I don't think either one of y'all
stand a chance all right no one I'm
ready and wow us let's go is poppin
looking real delicious got that baked
salmon fresh caught today
bloomin asparagus make sure you complete
delicious meal we got some salmon we got
some other thing I don't know what it in
rice that was cauliflower broccoli
risotto I mean it looked delicious I'm
excited about this I love to me in the
game what are you gonna get in first
I'm trying I mean bite into it is juicy
mmm that's actually really good
that's not bad mm-hmm whoo okay not bad
whose is great I'm not a saint
connoisseur but didn't is bad okay good
I love asparagus running to buttery
buttery of course I did this to know
we're so gonna be here he's like you put
butter
I think it's right holy love is it good
yes the whole plate is really good
though I do value the presentation the
whole platings really good oh my gosh
good diversity of
diversity this blade also makes me think
that maybe the guy behind this is the
guy for you
damn I said it put some greens on my
plate we haven't seen the rest right so
we can I did fall he can be the top not
yet
but didn't make us sick it's cute tastes
good
creativity oh my gosh love it I love to
hear it this look I mean sure sex is
nice but have you ever had anyone tell
your cook is good I mean Savannah is
really digging this but Lindsey the she
seems to be a little I don't think it's
any way I'm gonna be able to cook
tonight at 12 a.m. still wake up at 80
I'm gonna do my shoot and still like
make something worthwhile so it's time
to go to plan B I just got a second I
got a break I'm gonna go try to run and
grab some food for this but I gotta win
I want to win
[Music]
okay I see ground beef I think on an on
a fried egg turq I think it might be
sauce no I mean under it oh there's a
lot of oh maybe it's ground turkey okay
good well i'ma wait till they taste it
because we all are in unison that that
as a presentation wise it looks it looks
they're not afraid to think outside of
the box yeah it's just something that
I'm really excited about that's what I'm
talking about but I am concerned like
what meal is this supposed to be for is
this breakfast lunch breakfast baby
I think it's definitely breakfast
it's definitely breakfast okay so they
figured out that it's breakfast there's
a little seasoning on top so that lets
you know that the next dish is gonna be
Blake oh mama heat you in it's your turn
right now eat me I'm gonna eat her back
but it's okay I can help him with help
me let me she want to see me grow stuff
in nothing but taste is good mine yet
but is there's a chance that I could go
home with both days oh wow you really
know like you ain't even seen yours yet
same chicken carrots looks pretty good
to me
okay so I'm about to pack it up and
palete tomorrow the girls will like it
and
I will beat all the other guys and have
the best meal we'll see what happens
this guy is trying to fatten me up for
the winter wow I love a good lemon on
the side this is meant to do this yeah
Wow yeah this is like the ideas of
dinners you got to put it together
before you oh my god some hot sauce
alright try the carrots yeah they're so
soft way they're going carrots first
yeah okay it's almost like it said it's
tasteless Millie oh ho everything is
tasty first of all she already said she
loves to catch he's got an appetite
chicken breaded very nicely yes I don't
know it's cooked really nicely too wow
he really went all out with these like
elements yeah it seems like the carrots
hit the chicken hit but the couscous was
taste well the couscous no so the
couscous was tasteless yeah this one
lived up to its a period yes it was very
good the lemon was just wow oh I got to
I got to this guy isn't selfish he's
very giving I think this one was good I
think this one was definitely better
than the second one that we got a
hundred and ten
he could take one of those singles
cooking classes and then come back next
room you know I'll make you a nice
the other way for the reveal I want to
see your face it's just like one in
three were just they came with their
game face you know what I'm talking
about do we do that do we we reveal the
plate slash guy that I liked the best I
think is the first guy okay this this
plate is like a really really close
second
I liked serious Wow I just like I said I
put six eggs you did your face lit up
right when it came to the table so
chicken that was a rush thing was that I
thought that they will love a good
breakfast yeah yeah okay you know like
keep it light like I mean my feeling is
I don't think that you can make anything
but breakfast I have a feeling you do
you eat out don't you eat out alive what
I don't know I don't know man I don't
know we don't grab dinner he wanted now
he wants to replay and listen I'm
mourning it for the cooking thing like
you know but you know I am a good day
but really I have a passion to win I
just you want to keep it light you want
energy - technically I didn't lose I
didn't even come in second like I hide
for first there's only one loser
that's you congratulations on your dates
hopefully your time together is good all
right so the two winners have amazing
ladies yeah let's see if they're
disappointed psych this is what I look
like
yeah all right we're gonna meet the guy
behind ya all right first of all this is
very awkward
second of all I pick number three I pick
number one I'm a little nervous
no no I
[Applause]
today see he's a smart man
yeah do I know how to pick em or what no
the salmon the salmon leads to the man
did you fresh catch your chicken no also
explain your meal what was it it's
parmesan and crusted chicken with almost
you said big carrots who's comin on
topic oh that's what it was yeah but I
will say you're breaded chicken the
lemon we liked the lemon you didn't make
the lemon but that was but he always
love a good lemon yeah
oh wait wanted to know how you make the
carrots the carrots were bare yeah did
you follow chrissy teigen is recipe
there's a good care recipe ok I peeled
them I cut to put olive oil salt and
pepper to put them on a pan then put
them in this thing that's it that's it
you did a good job no food is something
that's really important to me just
because I do you try to live like a
healthy lifestyle so I do like the your
whole like thought process behind the
meal and just like the plating
everything about it was really good so
thank you so 10 out of 10 you have good
taste
yeah I could see myself going on a
second date with you for sure but you're
just gonna have to teach me to cook zap
oh yeah my food chicken I love carrots I
like eating lots of food and that's hot
all the things yeah is super good would
be down for another date cool
[Music]
Sam and gang
[Music]
[Music]